foreign
the internet
what began as an exclusive tool to
connect military's governments and then
universities has now more than 60 years
later transformed everything about how
modern societies operate and communicate
today no one can escape the grasp of
social media or evade the mind-boggling
connectivity that nearly all humans
worldwide now have access to
but few have been prepared for what has
also emerged with all this human
connectedness
Anew and ominous strain of human
behavior has been Unleashed
increasingly people are hiding behind a
cloak of anonymity waiting to provoke
harass and even threaten anyone they
choose they are called internet trolls
a troll is someone devoting large parts
of their life to attacking other people
on the internet basically trying to make
that other person's life miserable in
some way
they send things to my home it terrifies
me to think what they could do if they
wanted to knowing exactly where I live
knowing where my children go to school
[Music]
trolls can be a minor annoyance or a
life crippling Terror but what happens
if Society tries to silence them who
loses then
trolling is a free speech issue and if
you aren't free to hate someone then
you're not free
I've been associated with all kinds of
organized trolling groups we're
stretching the bounds of free speech you
either use it or you lose it feelings
will be her
politicians and the courts are now
grappling with who really is a dangerous
troll I've been called troll by very
powerful people that should know better
homophobe misogynist racist all this
stuff is just lazy people not wanting to
interact
Alan Elliott is at the center of a
landmark trolling case that might land
him behind bars and forever change what
any of us anywhere can or cannot say
online
if Mr Elliott is convicted of a criminal
offense watch out nobody will be safe
you better shut up because if you don't
you could be going to jail
[Music]
my name is Gina Crosley Corcoran I write
a blog called the feminist breeder and I
deal with a really steady onslaught of
very vicious and dedicated trolls
trolls can be really really sneaky when
you think about patterns of stalking
stalkers don't just do it really quietly
they leave their victim clues that
they're being stalked in order to scare
them so today I got a working person
store magazine addressed to the feminist
breeder with my home address my trolls
sent me this probably to imply that I'm
too lazy to find a real job besides
blogging so
guys hey come here pumpkin pie Gina's
blog earns her family a decent income
she writes about being a stay-at-home
mom but from a pro-choice modern
feminist perspective and a large active
community of like-minded women has grown
around her blog I like to see that
recognition response when someone else
goes me too and that's so validating
that's why I do it feminists are
frequently targeted by trolls Gina knew
to expect attacks but she's been
overwhelmed by the volume of abuse and
stunned to discover who her trolls are
the trolls and the really dangerous
people that I attract are themselves
mothers and have small children at home
they get something out of taking out
their frustrations on someone like me
they see me as a figurehead and they're
really angry about the attention I'm
getting from people and they want to
discredit me in any way they possibly
can
these people spend all day taking
screenshots of every word I type on the
internet they all pick it apart they
talk about my children they talk about
my clothes they spend an incredible
amount of energy focusing exclusively on
something that they claim to completely
hate and to me that's the difference
between someone who just disagrees with
you or someone who's really stalking
every move you make and those are the
trolls
Gina sees little difference between her
trolls and a stalker they want to see
her react and they know how to push her
buttons
a stalker wants to upset that person
they want to make them afraid and that's
what these trolls do they leave comments
in such a way that makes you feel afraid
of what they're going to do and say
they'll leave comments about my address
or my kids and they do it because they
want to get a reaction out of me they
want to see me lash out and it all feeds
into this sick and twisted entertainment
value to them
[Music]
what is it that motivates trolls
in London England psychologist Raj
prasoud believes the internet has
spawned and entirely new yet unexplored
set of human behaviors
psychologists and psychiatrists have
been somewhat taken back by the huge
amount of negativity there appears to be
on the internet and it may be that the
internet has Unleashed a kind of dark
demon within millions of people out
there in the General Public
we think that one of the things that's
problematic about the internet is it
normalizes extreme Behavior so because
you see a lot of people on the internet
behaving in an extreme fashion you think
it's more normal than it might actually
be and the other thing is it seems to
encourage a herd-like piece of behavior
if one person starts being negative and
a group of people piling behind them
there's a kind of cascade effect which
you don't see in ordinary life outside
of the internet
psychologists further believe that one
thing has compounded the effects and
numbers of trolls
anonymity seems to be a very important
factor on the internet in that it seems
to make people less inhibited about
doing nasty things it means that people
feel free to get away with bad behavior
because they think they're not going to
get called to account no one's going to
point the finger at them so the
anonymity effect seems very important
and may explain why so much dark and
negative and extreme Behavior occurs on
the internet but doesn't seem to occur
in in real life in face-to-face
interaction
but what inspires a troll what do they
get out of it operating out of an
undisclosed location in North America
one hardcore and self-professed troll
agreed to tell us provided we maintained
his anonymity
I'm wild goose and I'm a member of the
bill Wagoner crew and I've done a
podcast for the past several years
documenting Internet troll activity
hacker activity gamer gay anonymous
occupy
you name it I've been a part of it
there's a serious darkness in not only
us but I think in everybody online I
think a lot of people just don't tap
into the the power of anonymity and what
it can do for them when you're anonymous
you're free to do and say a lot of
things that you otherwise wouldn't do in
real life you would be powerless to do
in real life Goose joined forces with
like-minded trolls he met online and
they work as a team to offend and
infuriate as many people as they can if
you were to Google Bill Wagoner crew
chances are you'd come across a term
called Rip trolling when somebody dies
and their family puts up a memorial up
in their honor we might set up a
separate page or we might just go on
that page and create a Ruckus but the
idea is to get as many followers as
possible on that page and make it seem
as legit as possible so that we can
offend as many people as possible when
we start posting Gore and other kinds of
shocking material
[Music]
foreign
people when they are most vulnerable
like at the time of a loved one's
funeral is a Surefire hit for the troll
that's the easiest way for us to create
a mass effect is really effective when
you have all these these people who are
already emotional I got this bomb on
them
you know with the gore photos maybe some
kind of sexually explicit photos it just
it it sends their emotions into
overdrive
but what do the trolls get out of seeing
these distraught reactions
loves
l u l z that's the currency of the troll
and it's what they're after lulls are
laughs fun and amusement at the expense
of others the Wagoner crew will prod
people online for reactions the bigger
their response the more popular the
target becomes someone who gets really
animated and waves their arms around on
camera preferably or they'll scream into
a microphone on a podcast they might
start crying they become lol's cow
they're like an ongoing Target we love
that kind of reaction
we want to make them cry we love to make
them cry
the open internet is a playground for
goose and trolls like it and the stark
contrast to what they can get away with
in normal society is not lost on them I
I really can't I mean the the real
world's so uh boring and it's lacking in
lulls it really is I don't think we'd be
able to find this in real life the
internet presented something that was
never available to us before
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
today if you go on the internet you're
entering the domain of the troll
but where did internet trolling all
start this unassuming computer science
Professor May hold the answer and may
himself be one of the very first trolls
on the internet
I'm Dr Adams deal I'm an associate
professor of computer science at DePaul
University in Chicago I think I'm the
first recorded troll on the internet
certainly not the first troll but the
first one that was actually written up
this is a piece that is here because my
wife hates it called The Alchemist I
didn't really noticed but it sure does
look like a troll and I guess he's
stirring the pot
Adam would first access the internet
while attending University in the
province of Quebec Canada and it
wouldn't be long until he was stirring
the pot with his rise sense of humor I
was a grad student in 1993 at Concordia
University of Montreal essentially at
that time the internet was still very
nascent and at that point was just a
relatively small number of universities
that were connected together and there
was this kind of quasi-bulletin board
system called The News Network you had
for example a group like racked out
humor and people would trade jokes and I
guess what happened at some point was
that there were people on rect.humor who
had a certain pension for tasteless
jokes that was not appreciated by the
rest of the community and so the
tasteless denizens were kind of hived
off and started their own group and all
that tasteless was born
as the chat group alt.tasteless got
going the jokes started to get more and
more extreme but soon the jokes just
couldn't get the rise they wanted
I think it was a long hot summer and
everybody was kind of getting a little
bored and there was this idea that the
people of all.tasteless should invade a
news group and somebody suggested
wrecked up Pet Stop cats
yes cat lovers would be the next Target
and Adam would be the lead like any
Community they wanted to discuss
problems that their cats had so I guess
my contribution was that we should
actually engage them by writing a story
that would appear to be from somebody
who was genuinely concerned get them to
to respond a stealth attack so I created
a fictitious identity and it was posted
anonymously to rectal pets or cats
and what happened next would be
recognized by Wired Magazine as
something that had never happened on the
internet before I have two cats so they
can two-year-old female and chode Cho's
problem is that he has really stinky
shits paint peelers Adam's post was
vulgar and over the top but he took care
to keep it believable study goes in to
heat something fierce yowling and
presenting all the time while dinner was
cooking I tried to stimulate her with a
Q-tip because I had heard that one can
induce ovulation that way my day came
into the bathroom while I was doing this
and needless to say I don't think she
bought my explanation the cat lovers
however bought Adam's story Hook Line
and Sinker initial responses to the post
were very helpful and essentially
suggested that that City should get
spayed then slowly other suggestions
started popping up
as the off-color suggestions became
grosser and more extreme the cat lovers
were outraged and the alt tasteless gang
had a blast so what we did was we
essentially trolled you know where you
throw a lure out behind a boat and motor
slowly over the fish until somebody
bites Adam and the alt dot tasteless
crew had become the internet's first
gang of trolls
back then Adam was one of about 14
million internet users worldwide 25
years later there are three billion
people online and the nature of trolling
has evolved
what's happened now is that trolling has
taken on a meaning different from the
sort of fishing metaphor and more
towards that of the troll under the
bridge where someone will post something
and the responses will be very
destructive basically laying waste to
whatever's been said
in the early 1990s Adam and his friends
were trolling for fun but now negativity
is everywhere on the internet
back in London Dr Raj Persaud suspects
that we all have a potential troll
lurking in our psyches
the answer to the question of whether
we're all potential trolls is delivered
by a simple question have you ever
gossiped negatively about someone else
because if you have it is a sense in
which you were doing a kind of micro
trolling Behavior
it's not pretty but science has now
proven that putting someone else down
can make us feel better about ourselves
and there's a specific name for the
feeling that results psychologists are
taking increasing interest in What's
called the schadenfoid effect and
Chardon Freud is a a word from German
which is about feeling pleasure at
someone else's downfall
there are a lot of people on the planet
feeling low self-esteem feeling beaten
up by life maybe watching other people
do badly watching other people suffer
seems to correct your low self-esteem
deriving pleasure from the pain of
others is a characteristic we all seem
to have to a degree but psychologists
are now finding that hardcore trolls are
likely to express four dark personality
traits in Winnipeg Canada a landmark
study of internet trolls has now shown
that one of those dark traits stands
Above the Rest sadism say this do it
because they like it some people get
their jollies by being rude and
obnoxious and causing harm to other
people sometimes serious harm to other
people and it gives them pleasure
Dr Paul Trapnell and his colleagues have
confirmed that the internet with
millions of potential victims and
anonymity to hide behind is a playground
for people with sadistic Tendencies it's
a venue where a person can go on and and
ruffle somebody's feathers or embarrass
or humiliate them or make them feel
anguish and there is no consequence to
that and it's easy to do so that might
attract people that take pleasure in
harming people and that seems to be what
we found
trapnel and his team began their Studies
by focusing on people who frequently
leave comments on message boards a
significant number of them unabashedly
rated trolling as their favorite
commenting activity
then we asked them to also fill out a
number of Personality questionnaires and
those questionnaires included some
measures of well-known widely studied
forms of nasty Tendencies we found as
expected that the trollers were higher
on all of the malevolent traits it's not
a stretch but nobody had investigated
that with data and so we did so and sure
enough that's true
[Music]
let me illustrate what I mean by these
four dark tendencies that have specially
toxic social consequences
psychopathy we can be callously
indifferent by our Reckless pursuit of
things that we want
[Music]
in narcissism we are callously
indifferent to others by our pursuit of
grandiosity and wanting to hog the
Limelight wanting to think that we are
superior to other people
machiavellianism the pursuit of
strategic harm in order to benefit
ourselves
[Music]
sadism is a particularly malevolent way
that we can do harm to others and that
is by seeking to harm people purposely
because it's pleasurable to us
so all of us have the potential to be
dark in these four different ways and
indeed some people combine these
tendencies in ways that make them
especially dark malevolent individuals
and that is a very very malevolent
person this is not somebody that you
want to have anything to do with it all
definitely not
nasty individuals have had free reign on
the internet and trolling is on the rise
but more and more people are starting to
fight back
this accused troll has been forced off
the internet for three years by a
Toronto court and today his artwork has
been forced off these Cafe Walls by
Angry protests
Gregory Alan Elliott is in limbo
awaiting verdict in a landmark Twitter
harassment trial
when I use Twitter I use it as pure form
as an artist I just went this is a brush
this is some paint this is a canvas
I used it to comment on politics I used
it to help people but I just used it
every way possible one day I responded
to every tweet that came across my tweet
stream and then someone said you don't
have to respond to everything and I said
I know right but today I'm doing that's
what I'm doing as an artist and an
experimenter
at one point Gregory was sending 300
tweets per day he was a servant
sometimes crude and very opinionated
inevitably he made some enemies who
wanted to shut him up Chris Murphy
Gregory's lawyer explains how Gregory
went from volunteering to design a logo
for a feminist organization to being
arrested and jailed for three days
when Greg called me he had no idea why
the police were there and neither did I
obviously and it wasn't until sometime
after his arrest when he was in custody
that he first learned what the police
were doing there and it turned out that
there was a woman named Steph Guthrie
who had said that Mr Elliott had been
criminally harassing her on Twitter
the medium that Mr Elliott is alleged to
have harassed the complaint that Ms
Guthrie is on Twitter that's it no
personal emails not Facebook nothing in
person no in-person meetings no stalking
behavior
there's the one they threw coffee on you
can throw coffee on it but creating the
pictures worth more than a thousand
people destroying it this is like
freedom of speech this is saying you
know like
I can comment on what you're doing as
long as it's not a threat
you know if you're hurt if the truth
hurts you it's not it's not my problem
because I'm just telling the truth
Mr Elliott was disagreeing with
Stephanie Guthrie's politics she's the
founder of a political organization in
Toronto called women in Toronto politics
Mr Elliott was an ally of hers for a
number of months
but then there was a break in the
relationship because Mr Elliott stuck up
for someone he believed was being
bullied by Miss Guthrie and her friends
on Twitter
Miss Guthrie who refused to be
interviewed for this film asked her
followers to quote sick the internet on
a young man who had made an
anti-feminist video game a game that
even Mr Elliott admits was clearly
offensive
there was an orchestrated and dangerous
attack on this guy right after that
point I was sending Tweets to them
saying look the guy only has 11
followers ignore it it's not it's not
good branding you know to destroy
people's lives but they said screw you
Greg and I said okay well you're not
gonna take me seriously
um you're not going to stop I sent a
tweet that I'm going to paraphrase that
it said if you commit suicide I'm
holding you all responsible and at that
point
my helping stopped the attack started
and I had to start defending Gregory
didn't know what he was up against a
community had labeled him a troll and
they were determined to get rid of them
I knew they were trying to get me kicked
off Twitter so at first it was a
campaign of intimidation
second it was fake identities
using my face and names that were
similar to my names and that's illegal
and if I felt like it I could have got
overdid it kicked off Twitter
but then it was the hashtag GAE hole
Gregory Alan Elliott [__] so gay hole
so this is an orchestrated campaign that
ramped up
Gregory fought back with tweets that
were often abrasive and confrontational
but he never broke Twitter's terms of
service
that hasn't stopped the justice system
from charging him with criminal
harassment and imposing bail conditions
taking away his internet use for three
years
so what I've had to do for uh for the
three years to because I was banned from
the internet and banned from email
is I've had to rely on family and
friends and try and cut into their lives
and schedules
yeah and to be forced back onto a pencil
and erasers is very interesting I've
spent I couldn't even count thousands of
hours
like this sitting like this at my own
time because he was not able to do his
own evidence gathering for his case so
you have to the most painful thing is
having to go through stream of
Consciousness blather on Twitter not
exciting for me and I can imagine it's
even less exciting for everyone that was
helping me out so
sifting through the intricate web of
thousands of tweets and retweets made
one thing abundantly clear to Gregory's
lawyer Chris Murphy
Gregory Allen Elliott is not a troll
there's no way he is either
communicating
a political message or he's defending
himself against their slander
those two things do not make you a troll
he wasn't going near them physically
wasn't saying anything threatening
wasn't saying anything sexual to them he
was communicating about politics and he
was following the rules on Twitter
[Music]
but because Gregory wouldn't shut up his
accusers went to the police saying that
they felt threatened
now Gregory waits for the judge to
decide his fate
Freedom or six months behind bars
if Mr Elliott is convicted of a criminal
offense watch out because nobody will be
safe what you got to do if you're
involved in a political conversation
online and the mob comes to shut you up
you better shut up because if you don't
you could be going to jail
[Music]
thank you
internet trolling has two essential
Parts the attack and your reaction a big
reaction is what the trolls crave and
the way you respond determines whether
or not you are a worthwhile Target
if it's just somebody that's just gonna
you know block us and that's the end of
the game not only you guys suck that's
that doesn't provide too much
entertainment
prolific troll wild goose and the
Wagoner crew are all about the lulls the
laughs their victims provide they call
them plus cows so there's a logical
limit to how far they'll push them
there's a symbiotic relationship between
the Internet troll and the lol's cow the
bill Wagoner crew has never pushed
anyone towards suicide nor have we tried
to that's never our intent why would we
kill a perfectly good lol's cow if we
were to knock them off the internet or
out of real life what benefit would that
provide us you know how are we going to
get any lulls out of someone who's six
feet underground
you know
um last I looked um
dead people don't come on the internet
stay-at-home mom and professional
blogger Gina Crossley Corcoran faces a
politically motivated faction among her
trolls they disagree with her opinions
on home birth breastfeeding and the
Health Care system and they want to
drive her blog off the internet all
together I had a large reach but I don't
feel like it somehow makes me better
than anybody or makes me some sort of
powerful figure but they see it as very
powerful and that's why they want to
shut it down
a few years ago a coordinated trolling
campaign drove away all of Gina's
sponsors
there were a couple of brands that hung
on but ultimately they were like listen
these people are flooding our Facebook
page with negative comments and hateful
comments and talking about our families
now and we just can't do it so suddenly
almost overnight I had no income base
but I had what had become an expensive
blog to run
Gina took a chance and put up a paywall
fortunately it turned out that most of
her audience was willing to pay to be
part of the feminist breeder community
but the frustrated trolls have since
stooped to new lows
one of them called the police and told
them that I was committing suicide
so the police showed up at my house at
like three in the morning woke me up out
of bed
and said we got an anonymous tip that
you are suicidal
and we have to put you under a 72-hour
cycled
so I was being thrown in the back of an
ambulance
a crying you know upset afraid my
children were going to wake up and see
mommy being taken away
luckily I was able to talk to the EMT
and I explained to him like listen
this person you're saying from Twitter
this person doesn't know me please don't
take me anywhere I have kids to wake up
to in the morning and luckily he sort of
saw the situation for what it was and he
you know let me out of the ambulance and
said okay go back to bed
so I found out from the police that
anyone can make a call and say that
they're worried about you committing
suicide or they're worried about your
Children's Welfare or and anyone can
make an anonymous tip they don't have to
leave their name so there's really
nothing legally speaking that I can do
about that
my trolls realized that was a good way
to use my own local police to harass me
and get me out of bed at three in the
morning
in the course of a year it happened
three times
so I went to the police and I said this
has to be illegal and
you know the local police's response was
basically well if you don't like it get
off the internet
when the police cannot or will not help
there is another place that trolling
victims can turn
nice to meet you please come have a seat
the victims I deal with come to us very
frustrated they're frustrated with the
situation because they feel helpless
Roman harik is lead forensic
investigator at info Transit an
international cyber security firm he
tracks down the trolls that law
enforcement won't or can't find the
reasons why the police won't engage the
case is because they won't believe
there's the enough of a serious threat
or the one have the person themselves
won't have enough evidence
I've been getting a lot of people
threatening me online and it's scary I'm
not really sure what to do with this wet
sites mainly are they threats coming
through on mostly Twitter but there's a
couple on Facebook okay one of the big
questions is understanding the motive of
the troll there's some trolls out there
just scrolling the internet looking for
someone random to you know harass
however the vast majority of trolls that
we deal with are someone who they know
they would have had a relationship
somehow with their fender
[Music]
Roman and his team have discovered that
it is people we know family and friends
and workmates who are most often behind
the heinous attacks we can face
but Roman's team has also uncovered a
new more dangerous type of player in the
trolling game professional trolls those
who can be hired to settle a score and
attack others for money
online trolls for hire the service is
available online almost like a hitman
some of the guys are very professional
and they even create their own malware
targeted to that victim so they write
their own code these guys know what
they're doing these trolls For Hire
could be pretty much anywhere in the
world Romania or Ukraine Russia Lots
from there trying to track them down
often becomes an international operation
having to coordinate between different
law enforcements in different countries
but thankfully the vast majority of
trolls are outright amateurs who don't
really know how to cover their tracks
about 85 percent of people who are doing
these things you know trolling and
harassing people online are not tech
savvy most offenders are leaving a vast
amount of digital evidence every day on
I mean every every second every minute
right now pretty much everything we do
online is potentially archived
many trolls operate with a false sense
of security about their anonymity and of
the potential consequences they face if
exposed
in England the law has taken a hard
stance and a line has been drawn in the
digital sand
yeah send some Tweets in 2014 and end up
getting 12-week prison sentence for
those tweets
it wasn't her habit to abuse people
online but today Isabella sorely is
known as one of England's most notorious
trolls so what was Isabella's online
offense
in 2013 feminist activist Carolyn creado
Perez was campaigning to have a woman's
face appear on the next printing of the
English 10-pound note the public
reaction was largely positive but she
was also deluged by a torrent of abusive
irrational and threatening messages on
Twitter Isabella joined that mob that
particular night I was incredibly drunk
and I decided to go home and just send
tweets it wasn't about the campaign I
don't always care what's on a British
bank note I know she was camping to have
a woman and the Queen's on the banknote
anyway so I don't yeah I didn't really
not care at all what she was camping
about even now I don't even know why I
sent them I would love to know why and
I'd love to give like a clear answer but
the real phase is that I was drunk and
I've just jumped on the bandwagon and
followed a lot of other people
the trolls were not debating they were
spewing hate and attacking creato Perez
personally for her feminist agenda
Isabella added six threatening tweets of
her own she threatened rape and worse I
woke up in the morning like obviously
worse for wear realized what I'd done I
was physically sick I don't know if I
was down to the Tweet sort of The
Hangover I absolutely violate what I
tweeted was disgusting so to think that
I actually typed that out I felt
disgusted in myself that I'd sent those
specific words to another person
filled with remorse the night after
spewing her online hate Isabella took to
the internet to both confess and say
sorry I apologize to her when look it is
an empty threat do not worry I'm sorry I
don't know if it reassured at all but
kind of it made me feel a little bit
better that yeah she's getting all these
other rape death threats at least mine
is an empty threat just enough to worry
about me falling through with what I
said
but rape and death threats are taken
very seriously
four months later Isabella was arrested
along with another troll
her trial was widely publicized and she
faced the scorn of a Nation
I got um 12-week prison sentence in
hallway prison
it's hard
it was really hard because obviously
like how high profile it was I couldn't
hide away I had all the prisoners asking
why I did it had all like the prison
guards asking why I did it I was getting
a lot of abuse from everywhere I was
being made out to be a woman here and
obviously I'm in a woman's prison so I
was like oh dear now he got my head
kicked in because of what someone had
saw what I'd tweeted on the news I saw
myself on crime watch in the prison cell
so that was hard
after her time in jail Isabella was
ordered to do community service and also
pay money to Caroline creato Perez
personally for her online attacks
in England Isabella sorley's case was a
precedent setting one a very clear
message had been sent by the crown but
not everyone agrees with the
government's stance I think trolling is
a free speech issue I think what we have
is a situation where people are being
prevented from saying certain things
often quite shocking things and and not
very socially useful things you know
it's often just insults or abuse but in
my mind that falls under the category of
freedom of speech and if you aren't free
to hate someone then you're not free
Brendan O'Neill is editor of the online
current affairs magazine spiked he's no
stranger to controversy or trolling
well I've been attacked as an individual
all the time I get abuse I'm defamed I'm
libeld if I search for myself online
there's all sorts of abuse and sometimes
it becomes physical I've had an envelope
of human [__] sent to this office
um so you know you get abuse all the
time if you put yourself out there if
you express an opinion if you say what
you think you will get abused but in my
mind that's the price you pay for living
in a free society in which everyone is
allowed to express their opinion
today opinions are everywhere but
increasingly tolerance of opposing views
is not it seems anyone can be attacked
for saying anything remotely offensive
and the line between internet trolling
and what is called public shaming is
blurring
I guess in my definition that travels
like a kind of extreme outrageous
minority who will use kind of extreme
language with a public shaming
it's like nice people like us we'd tear
somebody apart because we're trying to
be good kind empathetic people and we're
the ones who really do the damage
because being torn apart by like tens of
thousands of lovely People Like Us for a
joke that lands badly on Twitter that is
profoundly and horrendously traumatizing
best-selling Welsh author John Ronson
thinks the social media pylons and the
public humiliation that many of us take
part in Daily is out of control
just before getting on a plane to Cape
Town wrote going to Africa hope I don't
get AIDS just kidding I'm white
and she chuckled to herself and pressed
sand and got no replies
got on the plane turned off her phone
fell asleep probably the last decent
sleep she had in
a year
Justine had only 170 Twitter followers
when she posted her now Infamous joke
but as she slept on that flight the
internet exploded when she woke up and
turned her phone back on she discovered
that she had lost her job and was now
despised by a global audience with
millions of people attacking her online
Justine's tweet overwhelm your timeline
yeah everybody me too I was in London
lag in bed and I thought what everybody
else thought which was uh wow somebody's
[__]
um
some sat up in bed
then I thought
I'm not certain that that was intended
to be a racist tweet
John Ronson was so unnerved by the
public response to Justine Sacco's tweet
that he went to see her
when I met just in a couple of weeks
later just crushed and broken and
mangled up I asked her to explain the
joke and she said Living in America puts
us in a bit of a bubble when it comes to
what's going on in the third world I was
making fun of the bubble I then came the
trolls
I'm actually kind of hoping just in Sako
gets AIDS LOL somebody else that night
wrote some of the HIV positive should
rape this [__] and then we'll find out
if her skin color protects her from AIDS
and you know what nobody went after that
person that night we were also thrilled
to go after Justine
you know we were so happy to be
destroying Justine we didn't have enough
space in our brains to destroy somebody
who was inappropriately destroying
Justine so that person got a free ride
with a public shaming you are being told
by hundreds of thousands of lovely
people that you are worthless and the
people who I met were who were really
crushed traumatized depressed a
smattering of trolls may have said we're
going to rape you and kill you but what
really killed those people was
was our righteousness
the line between bad behavior and
trolling is blurring and as Britain's
most notorious troll Isabella sorley has
found out the consequences are profound
she spent 12 weeks in jail for sending
six threatening tweets after a night of
binge drinking
20 minutes it's still defining my life
which I get I struggle to to cope with
that because it was such a short period
of time and it's all I'm always going to
have that stigma attached that I'm that
Twitter the Twitter girl
she's sorry for what she did but she's
not sure the punishment fit the crime
I think obviously what I sent if you'd
said it face to face you're going to get
in problem I don't think I would have
got prison
I was definitely made an example of
because of how high profile it was
[Music]
Abella would like to apologize to her
victim face to face one day but a
lifetime restraining order means that
likely won't happen
today she works with youth to educate
them about the dangers of alcohol abuse
which she believes ignited her trolling
Behavior but for now and likely forever
Isabella will have to live with the very
public and criminal consequences of her
online actions
thank you
[Music]
Free Speech Advocate and journalist
Brendan O'Neill doesn't mince words
thinks Britain is creeping closer to a
1984 George Orwell police state when it
comes to what can or cannot be said in
society he sees trolls as a scapegoated
minority Pawns in a game where much more
is at stake we present the trolls as
powerful and the trolled as these kind
of victims I think it's the other way
around I think troll Hunters the people
the usually the media people who present
themselves as these Brave Warriors
against offensiveness on the internet
they are the greatest threat to the
internet they are the ones undermining
the freedom of the internet the
accessibility of information the right
of people to express themselves and it's
the trolls the the sad man or woman
stuck in their bedroom talking rubbish
on the internet they are the victims
as governments legislate to deal with
trolling there may be unintended
consequences for everyone who
communicates online
and my concern with the way in which
trolling is discussed today is that
everything gets conflated so you have a
situation where trolling can be
everything from someone issuing a death
threat which is obviously a serious
thing to do to someone writing an
article saying I don't think climate
change is the biggest problem facing
Humanity
thing gets lumped together as trolling
and if you believe in freedom of speech
as I do you should be outraged by the
arrest not to mention the imprisonment
of someone simply for expressing an idea
[Music]
kilometers away in Toronto Canada
after three years of being forced off
the internet having his artwork
vandalized and wondering if he would go
to jail for the tweets he sent
the verdict in Gregory Allen Elliott's
case is finally handed down
he is innocent of all charges
the judge says his tweets contained
nothing of a violent or sexual nature
and there was no indication that he
intended to hurt his accusers
I was not doing anything wrong and I was
you know protecting myself and my
freedom of speech and uh and I wasn't
going to be bullied or intimidated by
people that were trying to protect the
world from bullies and Intimidators you
know for lack of better word you know
Gregory has his freedom but he's paid a
heavy toll for the speech his opponents
considered trolling
the emotional toll is brutal it's brutal
and the monetary the money and stuff I
lost my job of 17 years I had to cash
out my pension
absolutely just destroyed me financially
destroyed me financially
Gregory's reputation has also been
damaged even his most abrasive tweets
pale beside the trolling he received at
the hands of the Twitter mob
even though he was in the right
there is a permanent record that's going
to follow him on the internet of Mr
Elliott being labeled as a men's rights
activist a misogynist and a pedophile
and I guarantee you one thing
nobody who accused him of being those
three things is going to apologize
[Music]
Gregory's detractors say that misogyny
won
and the most vicious anti-feminist
trolls see his acquittal as a victory
tragically this case has done nothing to
make discourse on the internet any
better
meanwhile back in Chicago blogger Gina
Crossley Corcoran is tired
despite the validation she gets from her
feminist breeder Community the trolls
are wearing her down
constant snarky comments cruel pranks
threats against her family and late
night police intrusions
she's learned to manage it
but it's exhausting
I wish that people would use the
internet more as a buffet just take what
you want and leave the rest as opposed
to feeling like anything that doesn't
apply to them or anything that they're
bothered by is a reason to go on the
offensive you know when I go to the
buffet I I like the chicken and I like
the mac and cheese but I'm not insulted
by the other things that are there that
are might be useful for other people and
other people might find palatable I'm
just like yeah those aren't for me and I
walk away I don't like go up to the
manager and scream how dare you have
this available at your Buffet it doesn't
personally meet my needs but I feel like
a lot of people on the internet that
that's exactly the way that they react
will this new psychological phenomenon
of trolling ever end the answer is
likely no instead we need to gain the
tools to recognize how to fight trolley
and recognize how not to become trolls
ourselves
perhaps ironically notorious troll Wild
Goose advocates for anonymity and
cautions that are real physical lives
should be kept off the internet
altogether people need to disassociate
themselves
[Music]
from their internet Persona I I think
it's dangerous
to sort of plug your personality into
the internet you're leaving yourself
open to a lot of dangerous actors more
dangerous people than the bill Wagner
crew
privacy is just as big of an issue as
freedom of speech they go hand in hand
we think of our real world physical
lives as distinct from our online
activity but that separation as rapidly
breaking down
the biggest challenge we face as we
adapt to this change is maintaining our
freedoms in the digital space
freedom of speech may be the most
difficult to transition
for the first time in human history the
masses can express their opinions in a
published Forum I think that's a
wonderful thing and my concern with
troll hunting is that it's undermining
that Democratic breakthrough
physical threats should never be
tolerated but we may need to ensure that
others have the right to disagree with
us insult us even hate Us online
if we are serious about freedom of
speech then we have to allow people to
say hateful obnoxious racist sexist
things freedom of speech covers all
forms of speech
[Music]
thank you